(Laughter)
So while the doctors continued to operate
and put my body back together again,
I went on with my theory study.
And then eventually, amazingly, I passed my pilot's medical,
and that was my green light to fly.
And I spent every moment I could out at that flying school,
way out of my comfort zone,
all these young guys that wanted to be Qantas pilots, you know,
and little old hop-along me in first my plaster cast,
and then my steel brace, my baggy overalls,
my bag of medication and catheters and my limp.
They use to look at me and think,
"Oh, who is she kidding? She's never going to be able to do this."
And sometimes I thought that, too.
But that didn't matter,
because now there was something inside that burned
that far outweighed my injuries.
And little goals kept me going along the way,
and eventually I got my private pilot's license.
Then I learned to navigate, and I flew my friends around Australia.
And then I learned to fly an airplane with two engines
and I got my twin-engine rating.
And then I learned to fly in bad weather as well as fine weather,
and got my instrument rating.
And then I got my commercial pilot's license.
And then I got my instructor rating.
And then I found myself back at that same school
where I'd gone for that very first flight,
teaching other people how to fly ...
just under 18 months after I'd left the spinal ward.
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
And then I thought, "Why stop there?
Why not learn to fly upside down?"
(Laughter)
And I did, and I learned to fly upside down
and became an aerobatics flying instructor.
(Laughter)
And Mom and Dad? Never been up.
But then I knew for certain that although my body might be limited,
it was my spirit that was unstoppable.
The philosopher Lao Tzu once said,
"When you let go of what you are,
you become what you might be."
I now know that it wasn't until I let go of who I thought I was
that I was able to create a completely new life.
It wasn't until I let go of the life I thought I should have ...
that I was able to embrace the life that was waiting for me.
I now know that my real strength
never came from my body.
And although my physical capabilities have changed dramatically,
who I am is unchanged.
The pilot light inside of me was still alight,
just as it is in each and every one of us.
I know that I'm not my body.
And I also know that you're not yours.
And then it no longer matters what you look like,
where you come from, or what you do for a living.
All that matters is that we continue to fan the flame of humanity
by living our lives as the ultimate creative expression
of who we really are,
because we are all connected
by millions and millions of straws.
And it's time to join those up
and to hang on.
And if we are to move towards our collective bliss ...
it's time we shed our focus on the physical
and instead embrace the virtues of the heart.
So raise your straws if you'll join me.
(Applause)
Thank you.